All right. Hi there. Um
very nice to see you guys.
Um
it's it's like it's so interesting to
see like it's been such a long day and
you guys still showed up and uh I'm
always very flattered when like I'm
trying to present something and like
people are there. It just uh
I I if it makes you feel like you what
what you do matters. So, today the topic
that I want to talk about is like don't
build slop, four levels of AI agent
maturity. And what I'm trying to do here
is that I want to I want to talk about
something that like a lot of people
brought this up to me and there's like a
mass psychosis problem. So, basically
it's something like it's like every
person feels like um there's like these
like giant set of robots around all of
you that are just like kind of like
breezing through doing a lot of things
and and you're like in the middle and
you're so confused. You're so confused
of like what is it what what should I
do? Should I have like 15 agents like
ripping through all the time and I'm
just like live in or or should I just be
like a peasant and just like read
through every line of code? And it's
it's very hard to like make up your
mind. I feel like you come to a place
like this and you're always like the
formal just like gets to you. You get
like a panic attack or something. But
like I think I think I want to I kind of
want to pull back out of this and I'm
going to be like, "Guys, let's slow
down. Let's just slow down. And let's
think through like what are the problems
that we can like actually solve and I
will like actually help you build like
really useful agents. And I want to
take care of like every end of the
spectrum of like your necessity to build
things really fast, but at the same time
like your necessity to at a certain
point build things slow and take things
to production. So, that that's basically
um the goal. To give you an example of
like mass psychosis, like there's a lot
of things that are very similar. So,
I'll give you give you an example of
like three UIs.
And these are three Frontier Labs and I
guarantee you not one of you can predict
which one is which.
Uh one of them is factory, one of them
is Codex, and one of them is Cursor.
I I'm positive none of you know which
one is which. Even I don't know which
one is which. But yeah, so that's
basically the point. Like everything is
same. You you want to do your own thing.
So,
to build agents in particular, uh here's
what here's here's what I would have
would have present here. That I want to
break down this problem of building
agents into like four different parts.
The first part is just like kind of
somehow figured a way to like see if
this even makes sense, like this even
works. That's like where you use a
framework. Second part is like when you
actually are serious, like, "Okay, I
actually want to do something here." Now
you build things by yourself, like as
like a state machine, like building an
actual agent. The third part is like the
UX workflow, where you use Kanban, which
I suggest is like a great uh form factor
to be able to work with agents. And the
fourth part would be like shipping to
cloud. So, this is like mostly out
outline read of like how we want to be
able to uh work with agents. But I think
it will give you a good heuristics of
like how you how you would uh solve this
problem. So, level one of building
agents is like literally just like just
you just use a framework. And I I think
there's like a couple different
frameworks uh like LangChain, LangGraph.
Like I I wouldn't I don't use them. I I
I work at like client. I I I'm supposed
to like
write all the agentic experience stuff
by myself. So, why would I use a
framework? So, I won't be the best
person to give you advice, but I do
think that if you're trying to find PMF,
if you have a problem that's like, "Hey,
I have this problem where I want to be
able to I don't know aggregate emails or
do something like rudimentary, and I
think that like an AI agent would
probably be helpful here. I probably
don't care about the best model. I just
I just want something that works." Any
of the agent frameworks can give you
something that just works in like half
an hour. You can just write code this.
It It It's It's a great thing to get
started. It's a great thing to see that
agents actually do work and that you can
build them yourself. There are a lot of
pitfalls with uh using frameworks. And
one of the biggest ones that I think is
that like if you really want to take
things to production, if you really want
to build something serious,
very quickly you would learn that like
the level of customizability, the level
of like futuristicness, the level of um
modularity that you need, you just you
won't find them in a framework. I know a
lot of people who disagree with me and a
lot of those people are wrong. Anyway,
um so level two is like building
building your agents yourself, right? So
here's how you here's how you build you
like I feel like I feel like this is
like a very intricate problem like I
can't sum this down. So I'll I'll just
like give you like five rules of like
when you actually write code to build
your agents, like there there are five
rules that you could use.
Um and
these rules will like give you a rough
outline of like how to how to build and
write write code for your own agent. So
the first one is like you always want to
think of every agent as like a state
machine.
Um state machine is like a sophomore
year freshman year topic, but like state
machine is basically like every agent is
at the end of the day is like a
recursive loop. It's that's basically
like every every every hype cycle,
whatever you think, it's at the end of
the it's all the recursive while loop.
It's a while loop with a few conditions.
And no matter what your agent is doing,
it it always it doesn't matter it's
cursor clock or whatever, it is a while
loop with a few conditions and a few end
states. And what you want to be able to
do is that at any point of time, you
want to be able to have like a mental
model of which point in the state it is.
So let's say you want to be able to like
say um okay, so let's say you want to be
able to uh I guess read a few files and
explain them uh through clock code. So
it starts from the user task at the top
where you ask it like read a few files.
It goes to the state of like reading a
few files and like the action tool where
it reads the file, then it realizes oh,
I have read the file, it makes sense.
And then it'll call the completion tool
and just like complete and the the right
right thing at the bottom task complete
is when the state machine finishes.
Uh you can take this in a very complex
way where you can like rip through the
whole state machine for like 8 to 10
minutes or even like hours if you wanted
to. Uh but essentially every agent is a
state machine. If you can visualize that
as a mental model, then every time
you're building an agent it would be so
much easier for you to think through
that. Um the second rule is that every
single thing you add to an agent risks
making it worse. I think this is the
hardest thing that we've learned and
this has been a very bitter lesson that
a lot of agent builders have learned,
which is that large system prompts, lots
of different edge cases, lots of
different like fancy if else logic, all
of that for frontier models just just
makes them worse. Just like just just
get out of the way of the model is the
is the lesson that we learned, which is
that like
frontier models are so good at their job
that the less instructions you give
them, they actually perform better. A
classic example is if you go through the
Codex repo, the prompt for GPT-5 versus
the prompt for GPT-5.3 is 1/3 of the
size.
Uh part of the reason for that is that
the newer models are so good at their
job that giving them too many
instructions and longer system prompts
leads to a sensory overload where they
get so many instructions that they get
overwhelmed and can't figure out the
right thing to do.
Um so I think the simpler it is, it's
always better and it's like you have to
think that like every single thing I'm
adding, I I'll be very careful that I'm
I I hope to God I'm not making it worse
and just always try to prune it down. We
we took it so far where we literally
rewrote the entirety of client because
we realized there was so much uh junk
from the older older versions of client.
Client code has been written I think at
at least seven times from scratch, I
think. Um but again, um the the the
people on the team might know better. Um
the third rule is that you want to be
able to make agent an easy part of a
pseudo RL pipeline. And this is a tricky
one, but basically what this means is
that anytime you're building an agent,
you want to be able to have some sort of
like a CLI kind of a thing.
The reason for that is that as long as
you have something that can build and
test the agent really well in the form
of a CLI,
um you want to be able to build things
that are very easy to build and test
with
other coding agents. So,
right now there's this thing there's
this like interactive dance that's
happening between AI and humans where
and in the back in the day humans used
to like guide AI like do this and I
think at this point we're at the point
where humans are being guided by AI.
And this is I think is a part of that
where like if you're as a human you want
to be able to build things in such a way
that like the AI can work very easily
through it. So, that might entail
writing a writing you know agents.md
where you're using the right skills. And
building like a CI CI or CD such that
like the agent other coding agents can
easily build your agent, test it, make
changes to it and then test it end to
end is a very critical part because that
way if you want to make changes you can
just let let a long running agent run
through in a parallel thread. It'll make
all those changes, test it, and you have
the whole thing running. But, if it's
harder to build and test it would also
be harder for you to like use agents to
work on your agent.
Super meta. Um
Rule number four, don't be a slob. Guys,
don't please for the love of God don't
don't don't build slob, please.
I thinks that I think that there's
there's like there's so much like
throughput that you can get and so much
tokens that can go through really really
fast.
I think that the best lessons that we've
learned as like real engineers is that
like it's really worth spending some
time just like thinking through the
architecture, thinking through the
design, and the outline of what your
agent supposed to do, making sure that
it actually makes sense, and and just
like actually at least spend some time
reading the code even if you don't write
everything by hand. I think that that is
like for us we found that that to be
super critical because I think that it
it's
at least the architecture point of
building an agent has to be done by a
human and has to be done like very
thoughtfully. Even if you're using like
an agent to have a conversation with it,
spend a lot of time like try to think
through like what the architecture, what
the state machine is going to be. Don't
don't just let like uh other models like
rip through the code.
Um and then the rule 50 is Frontier Labs
kind of want to lock you down. And this
is a tricky one. A lot of people will
disagree, but basically what's happening
is that a lot of times when you are
working with the APIs of Frontier Labs,
the APIs are trying to lock you down,
and they make the interchangeability
harder. So, to give a very precise
example, the new set of models that have
come out, say Opus 4.6, uh Gemini 1.5 1
Pro, 5.3 They have this thing called
reasoning traces, and reasoning traces
are
um
a part of the cache, and they're also
the part of the reasoning uh uh test
time compute loop that the model does.
And when you have conversations and
back-and-forth conversations with those
models, you want to send the reasoning
traces in the exact precise format that
is expected. If you don't, the response
would still work, except that the
performance would be degraded, and you
would have no way of knowing.
And a lot of people are kind of missing
on the massive performance gains that
are coming from the new models, because
they're just like not using the APIs in
the exact precise way that they're
supposed to be used. Um and there are
asymmetries in the API. So, some would
argue that, "Hey, maybe you could use
Open Router." But I don't think that's
enough. I think you really want to be
careful that like if you're using
different Frontier Labs and different uh
Frontier Lab APIs, like they they have
you very carefully thought through uh if
the API is working correctly, and you
actually tested it.
Um so, the form factor is like the next
step is like the form factor of like how
do you like how do you visualize the
agents, right? So, I think originally I
came back to like in the one of the
previous slides, I tried to show you
guys like the thing where like Codex and
uh Cursor and others, they were all
looking the same. And I think I have a
different claim. So, for this uh
uh on March 26th, I made a tweet uh
where I said we people should use
Kanban. So, Kanban boards, I think if
anyone has used Linear, whatever, I'm
I'm all of you are familiar with Kanban
boards. So, my argument is that Kanban
boards are the thing to use.
Hans in in the audience was gracious
enough to offer me his thoughts as well.
So, thank you so much. So, Kanban boards
are are are this idea that like if
you're working through an agent, you're
always inference bound. A lot of you are
working through like Kodak's or Alpha's
and it's working for 8 to 10 minutes at
a time. Well, one of the agent is
working for 8 to 10 minutes. What do you
do?
You could doomscroll, but you can only
doomscroll scroll long. So, then you run
another agent, right? So, that way you
have at least like two or three agents
running in parallel at all times because
you're inference bound. And they're all
like mutating the same source
potentially. So, you want to isolate the
thing that they're mutating to take care
of that like the isolation of state and
then the inference bounding, the best UX
form factor to me is Kanban board mainly
because it takes care of it gives you
like it makes you like an engineering
manager which can look at all your
agents.
And you gives you like a headline level
view of what they are and it also helps
you build like flows with them that like
okay, if these two tasks finish first,
then I'll do the other task. And that
helps you like become like you you
basically become like an engineering
manager and all your agents are your ICs
and and you can
look at them through this.
So, I was making this claim on March
26th and 10 hours ago Clock Code came
out with the same thing. So, I believe I
was right.
Um
Um okay. So,
Yeah, you can use that through Clock
Code client wherever you can use client
as well, whatever whatever works for
you.
Um
So, yeah, so you want to think of like
Kanban is basically like an engineering
manager which you would be. Then there's
like a final step of like okay, you have
you have like an agent, you've tested
it, you've made it, and you you have a
good UX form factor to be able to like
interface with it and look at it.
What do you what do you do then? Like
how do you how do you how do you how do
you have an agent that's just like
useful, it works well,
but it it scales. It really scales for
like millions of tasks, millions of
users. If you're working for a company
which has So, 8,000 people, how do you
like how do you make sure that like all
of them can like very easily interface
with this? And I think that rather than
rather than like making people install
and like, you know, having these complex
workflows in the machines and stuff is
just is just so much junk and it's so
hard just like take it all take it all
out. Put put the hard work once. Just
take it all on the cloud. Um So, there
are many benefits of cloud agents, but
the primary one is that like you can
completely paralyze and have like a
separate machine for each of them. There
are like no local dependencies like in
the cloud like the agent can set up the
environment, do all the UX tasks,
because right now one of the most
missing pieces, the thing that a lot of
people are not using, that I use fairly
extensively, is cloud agents, because
they can really run really long. So, I I
on my phone often would send tasks that
would run on a cloud agent for like 15
to 20 minutes. So, let's say it's like a
UX change of like um go build this VS
Code extension. And this VS Code
extension I want you sign in here. I
want you click on settings. I want to
change the settings to um
uh pick this team. And then I want you
to test this thing in the terminal. And
the cloud agents are so good that they
will actually manually do all the clicks
of the Q&A testing that I just described
on their own.
Figure out if they work. And if they
didn't work, it will just keep
iterating, keep trying. And this thing
could easily take like 50 to 60 minutes.
But if you send like a lot of these
tasks in parallel through your phone or
through your laptop or whatever
whatever, um I think you you have like
you have this like really easy
customizable, extensible thing. And it
helps you scale really fast. And then
you could send it these tasks like
running in like the like the cloud
machine, like you know, like a messiah
and you could come back to your laptop
and then it's like, oh, you can just
pull down the PR and then you got the
whole thing going. Um the other aspect
of like cloud cloud agents is that like
if you're working with a lot of
different people um I think that it's
just like it helps you build like a
common set up that like so many other
people can share and so many people can
mutate.
Um so I think bringing that together, I
think would be like the final form
factor. So my my claim is that like
there exists a future where
um most of the UX of working with agents
would be Can Man and then most of the
actual compute uh that's involved with
uh with agents would be on the on the
cloud. Um I think these four levels of
frameworks are just like some the last
part of like, you know, Can Man and
shipping to cloud. Like those things are
very difficult and very intricate
problems. And I think that if I were
you, I would just like use this like as
like rough heuristics and start with
like, okay, let me just like let me just
do the bare minimum easy thing and then
just like depending on how much effort I
want to put in, I will like slide up and
down um up and down these levels.
So yeah, so that's it for me and yeah,
so um I I made a lot of hot takes. I
feel like I think I left a lot of like
open-ended questions here. If you have
any questions, if you have any thoughts,
this might hurt you, you're very welcome
to reach out to me, send me any
questions and uh yeah, um it was very
very kind of you guys to give me your
time. Uh thank you so much.
May I take a photo of you?
All right.
Okay.
All right, thank you.
And do you guys have any questions?
It's like I've got a minute.
All right, this is
Oh. Yeah.
How do you do planning inside of a Can
Man? Uh like
I I I find the sort of like back and
forth requirements gathering, you know,
the the
getting the agent to figure out what it
wants from me to be the most useful part
of it.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah, let me let me show you. Let me
show you. So, basically like I think my
interpretation of of of Kanban is that
like it's just like if you see the
screen, like you can go into any task
and it will give you like the entire
trace of the task.
Uh and that point it's like the So, this
this interface that you're looking at is
basically like um the actual CLI of
Codex. And I think I would I would I
what I usually do is just like have a
conversation here and then I know at a
certain point that like, bro, you can go
out on your own, do your thing. At that
point, I'll just pull out and just focus
on other things. And then does does it
transition state when it either needs
your review or asks you to
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. So, So, initially that is
like it's like let's say I would say
like if I say read a few files or
whatever, right? Um so, it would be like
initially it's in in the in progress
state and then when it's uh when it's
like it needs my input, it will go
through review.
Um yeah.
All right. Thank you.